[Musique]
le département et la région annoncé ce
mercredi 6 juillet la mise en place d'un
blocage du prix de la bouteille de gaz à
15 euros au lieu de 21 euros 88
actuellement et ce jusqu'au 31 décembre
une prise en charge de 6 euros 88 par
les deux collectivités
grâce à au partage de responsabilité que
nous avons le conseil départemental et
le conseil régional d'apporter aide et
soutien aux réunionnais aujourd'hui qui
subissent la précarité nous sommes dans
le champ de notre action le public du
département c'est aussi ceux qui sont
les plus modestes je pense aux cent
mille bénéficiaires du rsa aux femmes
isolées aux personnes âgées on sait
l'importance de la bouteille de gaz et
c'est un poil à le département une
action qui est prioritaire de pouvoir
baisser le prix de ce prix de la
bouteille de gaz donc là on va passer de
21 88 à 15 euros avec le partenariat et
la solidarité des deux collectivités
nous avons chacun m 5 millions dans le
pot commun pour satisfaire 7
mai deux collectivités interpelle aussi
l'état afin d'assurer la prise en charge
des 15 centimes de remises sur les prix
du carburant
[Musique]